permettez-moi d'abord de féliciter les
jeunes républicains et leur président
cheikh guilhem pour avoir su mobiliser
près de 700 jeunes à ce campus de
rentrée avec christian jacob nous avons
eu raison de vous faire confiance
je tiens je tiens à remercier aussi théo
charlotte tristan et le sénateur ses
fans pieds noirs mais aussi notre
trésorier daniel parce que lorsque les
jeunes sont venus nous voir pour nous
demander le coup de main avec daniel
avec aurélia nous avons dit oui est
vraiment vous fait l'événement excusez
du peu la rentrée des républicains
c'est ici à angers avec les jeunes
républicains à bâle
et je voudrais je voudrais remercier
tous ceux qui ont travaillé à ce succès
merci d'avoir associé à vos travaux les
responsables de notre mouvement lors de
tables rondes qui ont été très
studieuses
et notamment eric michel philippe qui
ont nourri si puissamment le débat dès
le congrès 2021 et qui ont confirmé ici
leurs compétences valérie pécresse n'est
pas présente parmi nous aujourd'hui mais
elle m'a demandé de vous transmettre ce
message je le fais bien volontiers voici
ce qu'elle vous dit si elle n'a pas
réussi à vous mener à la victoire elle
n'oubliera jamais ce qu'elle doit à
votre engagement votre fidélité votre
courage pendant la présidentielle vous
aviez 20 ans et vous étiez devant les
convictions que vous défendez sont
belles ce sont celles du général de
gaulle de simone veil vous pouvez en
être fier tout redémarre il a angers et
son coeur est avec vous
merci merci à nos présidents de groupe
olivier bruneau françois-xavier avec
lesquels je travaille régulièrement et
dont j'apprécie le sérieux et le talent
merci à aurélien notre secrétaire
général qui alimente le suspense je
salue les parlementaires les élus
régionaux départementaux les maires et
le premier d'entre eux cher david
lisnard certains ont fait beaucoup de
route cher jean luc
pour être parmi nous
et surtout est surtout merci à vous les
jeunes qui venaient de toutes nos belles
régions votre enthousiasme votre talent
votre détermination nous font du bien
permettez moi puisque je m'exprime en
tant que présidente de notre mouvement
de remercier tous les cadres de notre
mouvement qui sont là et une mention
particulière au gp
pour les applaudir
ce qui me réjouit chers jeunes
républicains c'est que vous croyez aux
valeurs de notre famille politique
et vous voulez peser sur l'avenir de
notre pays en un mot vous croyez en
l'avenir comme vous avez raison ceux qui
prétendent être les défenseurs exclusive
de la planète ne croit pas en l'avenir
il suffit de les écouter ils nous
promettent l'apocalypse écologique il
n'y aurait plus rien à faire mais il
brille mme quand même nos libertés pour
une cause qu'ils estiment déjà perdu
c'est ce que disait olivier c'est ce que
disait également bruno ce matin le chef
de l'état lui promet de la fin de
l'abondance de l'insouciance et des
évidences il nous promet du sang et des
larmes mais franchement franchement mes
amis n'est pas de choquer ni de gaulle
qui veut de gaulle et churchill avait
une vision de l'avenir emmanuel macron
navigue à vue cette incapacité à penser
l'avenir éclate avec la question
énergétique
l'affaiblissement de la filière
nucléaire est un drame aujourd'hui pour
nos entreprises je pense que beaucoup de
responsables politiques ici sont appelés
par des chefs d'entreprise affolée
affolé véritablement parce que l'énergie
le coût de l'énergie dans leur bilan va
peser 10 fois plus qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pour beaucoup d'entre eux la fin de leur
entreprise si nous ne dénonçons pas cet
accord européen qui nous tue
cette indécision et cette imprévoyance
au sommet de l'état nourrit le dégoût
des jeunes pour la politique à force
d'entendre que la planète est fichu et à
force de constater que les politiques
n'ont aucun pouvoir à quoi bon s'engager
ou voter ceux du style puisque tous
c'est à dire le pire est déjà écrit vous
ne faites pas partie de ces désabusé car
vous êtes les jeunes républicains
notre discours n'est ni déclinistes nuit
et gitan notre discours est un discours
de courage et d'espoir parce que nous
les républicains nous croyons en
l'avenir parce que nous avons foi en la
france nous croyons en un certain génie
français cher françois xavier pour
surmonter les crises pour inventer des
solutions pour préserver notre identité
nous en sommes tous conscients nous
avons devant nous des défis cruciaux
pour notre pays c'est d'explosion des
prix et le risque des coupures
d'électricité de 7 dès cet hiver une
hausse de plus de 10% des prix
alimentaires une pénurie d'enseignants
le réchauffement climatique le système
de santé à bout de souffle l'insécurité
grandissante et le délitement de la
cohésion nationale cher eric nous
n'avons pas le droit de laisser le
pouvoir continue à perdre du temps nous
savons où nous voulons aller rebâtir une
société fondée sur le respect de
l'autorité le mérite le travail la
solidarité la liberté voilà ce que nous
souhaitons ici tous qui sommes nous tous
qui sommes réunis
emmanuel macron a un don pour la
procrastination
il a une manie pour multiplier les
comités théodule pour réfléchir
concertée et réfléchir encore et en
définitive esquiver ses responsabilités
quand on a une majorité si peu cohérente
on ne décide pas quand on veut
satisfaire et les uns et les autres on
ne décide pas le en même temps est un
leurre le en même temps est une impasse
le en même temps est une faute au regard
des défis image de notre pays il se paie
au prix fort de l'inaction et du
renoncement il ya une phrase de victor
hugo que j'aime beaucoup qui dit ceci on
ne va pas aux vrais par des chemins
oblique disait victor hugo si justement
et je crois que emmanuel macron aime les
chemins oblique nous nous voulons aller
aux droits et à la vérité
le 2 août dernier
marqué les 100 premiers jours de son
second mandat
que s'est-il passé pendant ses cent
jours si on vous interrogeait que
diriez-vous il ne s'est rien passé ou
presque après le grand débat les cahiers
de doléances les convention citoyenne et
les multiples états généraux de son
premier mandat emmanuel macron croit
avoir trouvé une nouvelle parade le
conseil national de la refondation
il ose évoquer le cnr du général de
gaulle et de jean moulin je trouve
indigne indigne mes amis de comparer cet
objet politique non identifié que le
conseil national de la résistance qui a
fédéré tout ce que notre pays comptait
deux héros pour jeter les fondations de
la france d'après-guerre il est à mes
yeux impossible de confondre ce qui est
constitutif de notre identité avec ce
qui a tout l'aspect d'une manoeuvre
politicienne destiné à contourner l'un
des piliers de notre constitution quel
parlement les français ont décidé
librement de priver le président de la
république d'une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale ils ont démocratiquement
choisi lire des représentants de toutes
les sensibilités politiques
mais emmanuel macron n'a pas entendu le
message des français le débat
démocratique est essentielle à la
démocratie
il veut le contourner mais que cela soit
dit il va pourtant être obligés
d'entendre l'opposition notre opposition
et en particulier l'opposition que nous
portons avec olivier marc l'ex à
l'assemblée nationale avec bruno
retailleau au sénat parce que nos
solutions sont concrètes et applicables
ce président ne va plus pouvoir se
contenter de nous paraphraser il va
devoir admettre que nos propositions
correspondent à ceux dont le pays a
besoin et les mettre en oeuvre
maintenant que les choses soient claires
nous ne sommes pas les supplétifs de la
majorité nous sommes une opposition
utile forte d'un projet alternatif
nous ne veut s'y ferron pas sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale
nous faisons tout pour que nos
propositions soient transformées en
actes dès maintenant
c'est pourquoi avec le président du
sénat j'ai mis en place dès mon arrivée
à la présidence du parti une
coordination parlementaire avec les
présidents de groupe cette coordination
a porté ses fruits puisque en juillet
notre action commune a été entendu la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est nous
la conversion des rtt en salaire c'est
nous
la réduction des taxes sur les
carburants qui soulagera la france qui
travaille chez nous mes chers amis
je les dis
nous portons un véritable projet
alternatif
responsable un projet de gouvernement
cela suppose un impératif de
responsabilité le mot a été prononcé
plusieurs fois ce matin aucun dirigeant
je dis bien aucun dirigeant responsable
ne peut prétendre gérer un budget par la
dette c'est un point de désaccord majeur
que nous avons avec le gouvernement nous
sommes les seuls à tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé depuis des années sur l'envolée
de la dette et sur la dérive des
dépenses publiques il n'ya pas d'autre
voie possible
pierre mendès-france du temps où le
socialisme était autre chose qu'il ne
l'est aujourd'hui
il disait ceci et je reprends volontiers
sa phrase à mon compte les comptes en
désordre sont la marque d'un peuple qui
s'abandonne je doute que madame bornes
qui se réclament de la gauche soit
miraculeusement touché par la grâce de
la responsabilité budgétaire
pas plus qu emmanuel macron aucun d'eux
n'a jamais voulu résoudre réduire la
voracité d'un état toujours plus
dépensiers
pourquoi vote aurions-nous le budget
pourquoi veux tu aurions-nous un budget
même si nous parvenons à le corriger
cher olivier cher bruno si nous
n'adhérons ni au projet ni à la méthode
des manuels macron je n'oublie pas
évidemment sa meilleure alliée marine le
pen 2012 2017 ces deux là prennent
l'habitude d'une confrontation qui
tournent invariablement al'avantage de
macron pourquoi parce que les français
semblent bien que marine le pen est une
réponse impuissante à une colère
légitime
l'alternative mes amis c'est nous notre
responsabilité est donc immense et les
candidats à la présidence de notre
mouvement ne doivent pas l'oublier ce
qui nous rassemble est infiniment plus
fort que ce qui est supposé nous séparer
j'entends le projet d'eric j'entends le
projet de bruno j'entends le projet
d'aurélien ou celui de serge je les
respecte et je vois avant tout ce qu'ils
ont en commun
personne chez les républicains ne
conteste la nécessité de limiter
l'immigration pas plus qu'aucun d'entre
nous ne se satisfait dé l'application
des peines et l'explosion de la peine de
la délinquance chacun dans notre famille
est attaché à la solidarité envers les
plus faibles les handicapés doivent être
soutenus les femmes les enfants victimes
de violences intrafamiliales doivent
être mieux défendus qui s'y opposent
parminou absolument personne et nous
sommes tous d'accord pour dire que nos
entreprises sont trop souvent privées de
l'oxygène de la liberté que les aides
sociales ne sont pas un but dont on
profiterait au gré de son envie de
travailler ou pas mais une aide pour
ceux qui sont frappés par un accident de
la vie à mes yeux nous avons toujours
l'essentiel en commun mais parfois
certains expriment des priorités
différentes
veillons à ne pas en faire un combat de
ligne je ne connais qu'une seule ligne
la ligne droite
ses priorités mérite elle de se mesurer
l'une à l'autre dans le cadre d'un
congrès en tant que présidente je répond
que l'expression de chacun doit être
respectée chacune de ces candidatures
comme toutes celles qui se déclareront
dans le respect des règles pourront
s'exprimer chez notre richesse et notre
identité républicaine nous chérissons le
débat démocratique
tout au long de son histoire la droite
n'a jamais été menée lithiques cela a
été dit ce matin il y à une droite
légitimiste orléaniste ou bonapartiste
au 19e siècle
ces sensibilités continue d'irriguer
notre mouvement au 21ème siècle mais
l'histoire nous apprend et tu l'as dit
olivier nous apprend que nous gagnons
toujours
quand nous savons les mariés à la place
qui est la mienne je veillerai à ce que
le débat qui s'ouvre ne nous divise pas
mais qu'au contraire il nous
enrichissent je sais que les candidats
ont à coeur également de faire avancer
le parti messieurs je serai votre
arbitre une arbitre bienveillante c'est
ma nature mais une arbitre intransigeant
car c'est mon devoir pas de
tiraillements ni de faux semblants sinon
ce sera carton jaune chacun va devoir
jouer fair play nous les devons nous le
devons à nos adhérents qui s'engage
comme en français qui nous observent
j'en viens à une question qui m'est cher
moi qui ai exercé à peu près toutes les
fonctions dans ma fédération aussi bien
qu'à la direction du parti c'est le rôle
du parti de ces élus et de ses militants
jusqu'à présent le parti était dirigé
par celui qui espérait logiquement porté
nos couleurs à la présidentielle ce
n'est plus le cas c'est un changement
majeur
nous connaissons ce qui dans nos rangs
ont manifesté leur intérêt pour la
présidentielle de 2000 27 il souhaite
tisser un lien avec les français d'une
certaine façon ils ont raison c'est la
logique de la cinquième on élit par un
parti on élit un homme ou une femme
mais aucun d'entre eux n'a souhaité
prendre la présidence de notre mouvement
aujourd'hui nous devons donc nous
interroger sur le rôle du parti dans ce
contexte général nous savons tout ceci
que pour gagner une présidentielle
outre ce lien personnel avec les
français il est indispensable d'avoir un
mouvement politique derrière soi et même
d'en avoir été l'un des dirigeants
c'était le cas des deux finalistes du
second tour de 2017 maquereau et le pen
c'était le cas des trois premiers
arrivés en tête cette année elle sut ces
trois-là abandonne la présidence de leur
formation officiellement ils en restent
les maîtres à penser
pourtant les partis ne peuvent plus se
contenter d'être des écuries
présidentielles
nous vivons dans une société où la
politique est constamment d'évaluer où
les acteurs politiques sont déconsidérés
je vous assure qu'il faut une bonne 2
d'inconscience et de courage pour être
aujourd'hui un responsable politique
dans les médias dans les émissions de
divertissement dans la production
culturelle la politique et la plupart du
temps moquée
présenté sous un angle négatif les
jeunes générations je ne parle pas de
vous les jeunes républicains qui nous
avait bluffés ce week-end avec ce
rassemblement et avec la qualité de vos
interventions les jeunes ne voient plus
que des caricatures de la politique je
vous demande d'être lucide
pensez à vos amis qui ne sont pas
investis en politique comme vous avec
lesquels vous ne parlez jamais politique
un jeune âgé de 25 ans aujourd'hui quel
âge avait t-il en 2012 quand nous avons
quitté le pouvoir national en 2012 il
avait tout juste 15 ans que sait-il ce
jeune
de la droite en réalité ce que lui
disent les réseaux sociaux je ne vous
fais pas de dessin ils ne pensent pas du
bien de nous mais nous ne verrons nous
devons être lucides et sans complaisance
avec nous mêmes nous devons nous poser
cette question même si elle est cruelle
aujourd'hui les idées de droite et du
centre sont majoritaires mais quel est
le parti qui incarne ses idées les
médias nous disent que c'est macron et
même le pen quand tu ne nous dise pas
que nous sommes déjà morts mais mes amis
nous ne sommes pas à vendre à la découpe
et même si nous sommes affaiblis nous
sommes bien vivants notre rôle en tant
que mouvement politique et j'insiste sur
cette idée c'est de réidentifier la
droite et le centre à notre formation
politique
il est aujourd'hui aussi de former les
consciences à la réalité de l'action
publique les partis ne peuvent plus
vivre repliés sur leurs militants
pourtant si dévouée si précieux nous
devons nous ouvrir à ceux qui doutent de
la politique nous devons créer des lieux
de rencontres autour des idées des élus
des intellectuels des experts des
chercheurs pas uniquement pour
convaincre mais aussi pour favoriser la
réflexion politique je prendrai très
prochainement des initiatives en ce sens
le non cumul des mandats a bouleversé
l'organisation de nos structures le
député maire ou le sénateur-maire qui
siégeait au sein de nos instances de
direction a perdu ce double engagement
chacun le reconnaît y compris auprès des
promoteurs de cette loi c'était une
erreur nous y reviendront peut-être je
ne sais pas en tout cas ça le mériterait
mais dès maintenant nous devons réduire
la fissure entre les élus locaux et les
élus nationaux cher jean luc cher ami mr
il ya beaucoup de parlementaires qui
siègent dans les instances de notre pays
il faut que nous fassions une part plus
grande à nos élus locaux cher daniel un
dernier mot je vais être bref car c'est
un sujet sur lequel je reviendrai dans
les prochaines semaines mais vous êtes
encore plus concernés que d'autres je
veux parler des femmes nous assistons à
la montée d'un féminisme excluant pour
lequel l'avenir des femmes seraient dans
la revanche vis-à-vis des hommes ce
n'est pas ma vision est évidemment je
défends la femme républicaine définis
par notre devise liberté égalité
fraternité tout il y ait la femme
républicaine est libre égale à l'homme
elle n'est pas son adversaire n'est ce
pas chère anne laure n'est ce pas cher
michel n'est ce pas cher charlotte et
vous tout qui est dit ici cher alexandra
non je vous encourage à vous investir
sur cette question comme je compte le
faire moi même pas de renouvellement des
pratiques dans notre mouvement sans les
femmes ne l'oublions pas
applaudi ces messieurs
vous le voyez cette rentrée riche de
promesses un travail et des débats
passionnants nous attendent nous avons
deux ans devant nous avant les élections
européennes cher françois xavier pour
tirer profit de ces débats sachons le
faire en préservant notre unité c'est la
condition absolue de notre avenir vive
les républiques aviv les jeunes
républicains vive la république et vive
la france
[Applaudissements]